quote am I going to jail shocking moment
a six-year-old girl is committed to a
mental health facility without her
parent's permission where she was
sedated and kept from her mom for two
days because her school said she was
quote out of control where is this where
is this so this looks like it's let's
say Florida go figure
for sure top floor des before we read
this story I have to point out a
classical episode of South Park which
you may have seen it was an episode
about ad ad D and they were like this I
I'm gonna I'm gonna ruin the joke I
guess it's been so long since I seen it
but there's a video where I doctors like
I have a non medicinal treatment for a
TD and so he shows these kids in chairs
like bouncing around all crazy and he's
like notice the child is not paying
attention and is very exuberant with
lots of energy and then he's like now
the simple solution without any medicine
and he walks over and he whacks the kid
in the head and goes shake Jared shut up
and the kid stops moving and he goes now
you'll notice the child has stopped
misbehaving and then he walks into the
next one
and he's like notice this child is not
even paying attention to me and then he
whacks him shut up and the kid just
stops anyway they're making an
interesting point about how I don't
think smacking the kid is the right
thing to do right but it shows how I
don't know what happened with boomers
that blame boomers I'm sorry I blame a
lot of them not all of them there's some
good ones okay but we you have a bunch
of these people who want to be the cool
parents yeah and so when the kids acting
out they're like yeah whatever you say
uh-uh you know I'll go buy you the beer
and cigarettes and it's like how about
you be the adult and tell the kid well
you know you know it happens because of
it you end up with money allow are doing
that to their cats so instead of having
kids to discipline they're just having
cats and when the cat scratches them
they go Oh silly baby you cut my hand
open yeah now I'm cat crazy yeah you get
toxoplasmosis my parents always used to
tell us because my parents were not
typical boomer parents my parents used
to tell us that you will have lots of
friends but you only have two parents
yeah they were gonna act like parents
and you'll go out and make your own
friends on your own time reminds me of
American Dad there was an episode where
the dad Stan becomes friends with his
son and then like his son gets trapped
in a gorilla enclosure
and then the adult gorilla is talking
with his son gorilla and the son
gorillas like you know the the the
gorillas dad is like give that you know
kid back to his father and he's like but
his dad's letting implying he goes
that's no father he's being a bad parent
like the gorillas know better anyway
let's read the news good one police body
cam footage has emerged of the moment a
six-year-old girl was escorted from her
elementary school in Florida by a group
of cops before being committed to a
mental health facility out of control
and remain this is insane to me that
they would call the cops look she's just
standing there what look it's a little
kid she's just standing there like a
like a little kid at a temper tantrum so
they called the police yeah like how in
an effect I will argue you're the
parents why wouldn't you just put her in
timeout what exactly yeah dude it's it's
have you heard the stories from Chicago
though what ship in Chicago they're
putting kids in petted rooms and just
like locking the door and leaving
solitary confinement in schools yeah
yeah they have like padded room a padded
room yes yep and I'll take the kids who
are having tantrums and lock them in
solitary and just lock the door and
wouldn't leave and there was one kid he
was like seven years old crying covered
in his own waste saying yuck I made a
mess because they wouldn't let him out
you'd go the bathroom or something
yeah it's torture they're torturing kids
let's let's relive let's read a little
bit of this but I got I got I got worse
sport worse news for you they say on
February 4th six-year-old and Nadia Falk
was taken to a mental health facility
without her mother's permission after
staff at Lovegrove elementary school
called social workers claiming the girl
who has ADHD and personality disorder
was throwing things and harming staff a
six-year-old girl dude come on man
seriously nadia was taken to a mental
health facility where she was sedated
and held for 48 hours without seeing her
mother Martina
now Martina is also speaking out about
the horrifying ordeal and questions over
why the child was treated so harshly are
being asked in Florida children may be
removed from school transported to a
psychiatric facility and held for up to
72 hours without parental consent if
there is reason to believe they have a
mental illness and they're unable or
unwilling to accept voluntary treatment
that's so great Martina expressed her
hurt at seeing the footage of her child
being taken from the school in
Jacksonville
before being sent to a river point
behavioral health center it was so calm
there it doesn't even tease
just like yeah right so you're taking me
away it's like and it's like well one's
dragging her away she's walking with
she's Walker she's like I don't mind buy
it I don't buy a dick ulis I think you
got a little kid on a tantrum and you
got lazy school workers who are like I
don't want to deal with this hi you've
got being a parent you've got exactly
the entitled generation being not my
responsibility
take her away no one is taking
responsibility these kids are gonna grow
up to be like seriously deranged yeah
and like sadistic and it's it's this
whole thing is the whole system I kind
of can't believe that they're allowed to
hold children for 72 that's nuts without
even telling their parents cuz I was
gonna say I feel like that mom has a
really good case against the school yeah
legal what but it's legal hold on it's
legal I'm not a Baker Act what no no see
y'all don't understand oh my goodness oh
yeah real more than thirty thousand
children under age ten have been
arrested in the u.s. since 2013
according to the FBI that since thirty
thousand four hundred and sixty-seven in
what reality does it make sense to
arrest children now now hold on now hold
on now if there's a seven-year-old kid
he's got a gun or something sure I get
it if there's a little kid and they're
nuts
you ever see you ever see the problem
what is it the was it wasn't called
prodigal son or something with Elijah
Wood and Macaulay Culkin I think it was
son the good son yeah and like the one
kid was a sociopath and sadistic and it
was a good movie actually was I haven't
seen it it was actually good well okay I
get it it was crazy but let's see let's
see got a nine-year-old and he pulls out
a knife cuz there have been stories
about kids you know hurting other kids
maybe it's sociopath baby's gonna don't
know you've hurt a dog or something that
makes sense I don't know exactly what
the context of these arrests are but
I've seen so many stories about little
kids getting arrested for dumb things in
school we've seen the story from Chicago
about the the kids being put in the
padded cells yeah so we've got a serious
problem with adults who won't take
responsibility I don't know what
happened or when it happened
but it reminds me of that saying what is
it hard times make strong men strong
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
have you ever heard that no but
it makes sense yeah it's been so long
since our generation not even our
generation our society had real
responsibility yeah that now it's like
it's exactly what we were saying with
this little six-year-old girl you get
this little girl thing a tantrum and
they go not my kid not my responsibility
I get the vibe that that's probably what
her parents are thinking - yeah not
responsibility whatever
there's cool spots take care of that
school will yell teacher it's the me me
me Society yeah everything is about
what's for me and that's why we're
ending up with you it's really funny
what did you what did you call bucko a
love slave animals in yeah and all sets
all pets are love slaves I mean that's
what they're so we're it used to be that
you'd have a kid and you earned love by
being a good parent yep and it was
difficult we know I just capture small
animals give them names and chop off the
balls you know and now we have love
slaves you know that will you know their
family line is over but they provide us
that satisfaction of taking care of the
smaller life form yeah it's for us that
needs you it's also more needed it's you
know it's a it's a thing and now what
ends up happening is when you put these
kids the actual children the next
generation or this is this is called I
think it's called generation alpha like
six-year-olds right now okay man they're
gonna grow up to be it's gonna be like
you you ever seen Batman Beyond yeah so
you know like oh is it the cartoon yeah
it's they all have it's it's the future
of Batman and there's the Joker gang
okay so it's like there was the Joker in
the earlier times and then in the future
basically copycats form like the Joker
game that's gonna be these kids are
gonna be like the Joker it's like if you
see in the Joker movie yeah when he says
what do you get when you take a mentally
ill man you know take and you abandon
him yeah and then make fun of her
whatever particularly all his you know
all the help that the government was
giving him and then you know make fun of
them mm-hmm so what do you think's gonna
happen we have thirty thousand kids now
I think it's I think look at so actually
this story is prompted by the arrests of
two six-year-old students in Orlando
once again Florida the job Florida well
I mean right we talked about it though
look at this for the record the officer
fired the officer got fired oh wow who
restrained one child's hand with
flex-cufs
mirrors of persistent problem
confronting law enforcement and schools
with thousands of children arrest
annually and treated like many adults
they are just criminals it's this is
crazy you know you know I think the
problem is what our current our current
society is completely immature and
hasn't grown up how I was thinking about
this because I was wondering why all of
our presidential candidates are in their
70s yeah okay not all of them you know
you got pretty much the frontrunners
though right the the big names I mean
now you got booted Jeb who's I said
booted Jeb by the way who is you know
almost he's a millennial he's 38 but I
was thinking about and I think it's this
cuz I want to it's not about politics
it's about people our age do not view
themselves as parents they do not view
themselves having a responsibility to
these kids right so when the kid shows
up they're like I don't have any kids on
purpose I don't want to deal with this
call the police the police can deal with
it yeah and then when they're looking to
leadership they're not thinking I should
do it they're thinking they should do it
and they're pointing to the older
generation like this is your
responsibility not mine at a certain
point I feel like we lost that sense of
no one's going to do it but me yeah and
you had people who are like I must run
for office no of course we have a lot of
Millennials you know who are in industry
and ours being successful but I look to
what's going on in politics and it says
to me and this specifically that these
people are permanent children and they
don't feel that they have any
responsibility to any of these kids so
let the police take care of the
government take care of it I see a lot
of that in the adulting is hard meme oh
geez
yeah adult thing is her adulting is not
hard seriously
learn how to be an adult and it gets
easy if you just learn how to do it I
mean practice we talked about school
doesn't prepare you yeah true but you
can either do two things you can sit and
say adult things heart what was me or
you can learn how to be an adult and do
things they won't do it man I know like
if I had to begin to explain to somebody
how to start multiple businesses yeah
and set up all of this like mind you
night like when it comes to the cameras
the computers the monitors the tech and
everything
the graphics like everything for my
channels I have done completely on my
own and now that we're doing this new
show now I'm bringing in people like
Adam who actually Adam Adam built all
this did all of us yeah did anyone teach
you how to do like
did you call for help and like call your
dad and say dad how do I put foam on
boards no but I actually have called him
in the past about specific trade things
I just grew up in the trades but I dunno
no I didn't I built this all just I was
like yeah this is what I'm gonna build
right examine did it so like I don't
know what it is and I'm not saying you
can't call your parents for advice no
I'm saying like did you say someone else
please do this help me I can't do it no
but if I saw if I saw you know I've been
yelled at I taught skateboarding for a
while and I would always teach you know
probably like six to 12 year olds and I
have like forty cousins and all sorts of
kids in my family so I've always been
around kids so the kids don't scare me
and I talked to them and whatever but
you know I've been I've been I've had
parents get angry at me because their
child was rude to someone else to
another kid and I'm like hey you don't
do it you don't talk to other people
like that don't tell that snowflake and
they're like whoa whoa what do you do
did you just like tell my my kid like
snowflake how to how to be and I said
yeah I did like what I'm teaching then
and that kid liked me a lot and kepco
was like no no I want to keep keeping
his class I want to keep keep with him
upon it sorry sorry yeah but it's like
it resonated with them and he didn't get
mad at me didn't get angry he he
actually it was probably a cooler kid
because of that it's like I think it's
it's kind of like what Jordan Peterson
talks about Nick Ulis that kids actually
like discipline and being given
responsibility and yeah and they don't
respect you know and people don't
exactly they lose respect they lose the
respect for their even their own parents
when their parents I mean they see it
they're smart that's why I mean I talked
kids like they're adults like they're
huge that's how I do it and it's like
when you talk to a kid like a kid
they're like you're treating me like a
kid again they're smart well hey man
I'll tell you what maybe arresting these
kids they may be getting arrested is the
right thing huh
cuz hey it's you get a quick dose of the
real helping it's jumping way past what
they like way to the future when they're
not they're not criminals they're
they're still they're trying to figure
out how to be humans no one's taught
them how to be humans yep how are we
arresting them well they're I don't know
ridiculous
we're gonna say something yeah so I
think if they just need structure and
that is not in the form of being
arrested
not in the form of being spoiled to
death well yeah well we have we have
structures all gone the structures all
gone in America yes we don't have that
anymore we don't have like the classic
you know the man and the girl you have a
kid and then they grow up in the same
household with all the same friends in
the same neighborhood and go to school
together with the same people it's like
that does not exist anymore we're so
fragmented ya know so everyone's doing
their own thing they're so caught up in
in trying to live in this world cuz
adulting is so hard you know so crazy to
me because you know growing up I think I
think it has to do with the people who
are active on social media
mm-hmm lieutenant you know up
upper-class college-educated you know
whatever okay and so adult thing is hard
because it was always done for them
either their parents did a forum or the
the school administrator to inform their
teachers told them what to do and how to
do it
right I never had to figure it out on
their own so they literally think it's
hard to be an adult I'll tell you what
no you're just lazy when you want to
start a place on I'm thinking I'll tell
you it was not easy
yeah yeah but you got to work for it
they choose no but like I had no idea
how anything worked and that they send
me this big packet of forms and they're
like there you go and I'm like what am I
supposed to do with any of this and
they're like no one ever taught you or
anyone else the laws of each state are
completely different and good luck yeah
and I was like oh I figured it out it
was it was not easy
seriously it was that was there's very
you know you know what I don't get
stressed by a lot of things okay you
know that's neither do I the things that
get stret that stressed me out are like
I don't know there's like explosions and
bullets flying yeah and filling out all
these paperwork all all the form
certificates it is not easy to start a
business in this country now it's
probably easier than some places but man
it was ridiculously convoluted
complicated and inconsistent yeah
and now even even now I'm confused and
you know the funny thing is like so now
I have an accountant he's you know it's
basically like everyone's confused
whatever just give the IRS what they say
when they want it I'll tell you what
they want and they'll basically leave
you alone yeah and I'm like whatever man
hey it's been fine yeah we'll see how it
goes tax seasons coming up thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we're live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. and if you want to
catch the full record
Podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
youtube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to Like
share and subscribe if you wanna get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you